remember Tai Lopez
bought this uh new Lamborghini here fun
to drive up here in the Hollywood Hills
he dominated YouTube ads in the
mid-2010s with this quote-unquote
knowledge Ty's video format was pretty
simple he usually recorded himself in
front of flashy things like Lamborghinis
private jets and mansions but in the
video itself he usually dismisses these
materialistic objects and claims that
true God is knowledge he would go on to
claim that you can get this by buying
his extremely cheap courses that only
cost a few thousand dollars each while
this was a pretty simple pitch it was
also extraordinarily effective something
about him recording on his phone and the
low production quality gave his videos a
sense of authenticity there was of
course people who always hated this guy
and thought that he was a scammer but
there is no denying that his videos were
quite persuasive and hard to ignore if
you go through his comments today you'll
see people saying things like five years
ago we were forced to watch this today
we look it up and enjoy it we've come
full circle I used to never be able to
escape this ad and here I am years later
looking it up with comments like these
you know it's an internet classic but
despite his popularity in the mid-2010s
Thai more or less a lot of relevancy in
the later part of the decade ended
throughout the 2020s he never really
stopped posting altogether but his
telemetrics were on a substantial
decline his subscriber count stalled at
1.3 million and was actually starting to
go down meanwhile he was only getting
tens of thousands of views per video
which was terrible for someone who was
once getting Millions per video this was
until recently when he hit the YouTube
algorithm once again and boy oh boy he
hit it bigger than ever in the last 30
days Tai was able to pull in 170 million
views and gain over 200 000 subscribers
and this wasn't just a one-time fluke
either Tai has been pulling these
numbers since August so here's the rise
fall and ride as again of the most
infamous internet marketer of all time
Tai Lopez
taking a look back Ty's internet Journey
starts long before his Fame as a meme a
new Lamborghini in fact it end dates all
the way back to 2007 at which point most
people would have described him as a bum
according to Tai himself he was living
in a trailer park with 47 in his bank
account he didn't have a college degree
went to work experience or any
connections resulting in this less than
ideal situation but he was determined to
make changes so he grabbed a Yellow
Pages book from his kitchen it went to
the finance section and it looked for
the biggest ad on the page he figured
that whoever was paying for this ad had
a lot of money and more importantly you
know knowledge so Ty Tracked Down the
man who is paying for this ad and it
turned out to be some guy named Mike
stainback Tai would offer to work for
Mike for free in return for Mike
teaching him what he knows and Mike
would agree and that this is what would
eventually lead to Thai starting his
first online business in 2007 and lead
to Global dating LLC as the name
suggests this was a dating website and
honestly Tai was actually way ahead of
his time Tinder for example wasn't even
started till 2012 and today it wasn't
well above a billion dollars per year in
Revenue but maybe Tai was a bit too
early as he struggled to Garner very
many users and it didn't take him long
to switch to sketchy strategies at least
according to allegations The Story Goes
that Tai created it and ran a bunch of
fake profiles with pictures of
attractive females while some people saw
through it and left terrible reviews
many Sims fell for it and you just have
to take one look at a popular website
today to know just how lucrative this
can be Tai would use the money that he
made off this website to start a
nightclub in Hollywood and before you
knew it he was actually pretty well off
he could have called it a day right here
but it was clear to Ty that the real
opportunity was the internet so in
mid-2014 he started posting on his
YouTube channel about the books he was
reading and the main takeaways he posted
about a dozen of these but none of them
really gained much traction so so in
early 2015 he would give a TED talk to
hopefully grow a larger audience and as
you might have guessed the Ted Talk was
about reading books as well this
definitely gave him a push forward but
the real leap didn't come till summer of
2015 when he decided to film a video in
his garage and a run paid ads this ad
basically became ubiquitous across
YouTube and while many were complaining
some went down the Thai Lopez rabbit
hole and that's all he needed through
his next several videos Tai would
solidify his own credibility by
collaborating with already credible
people for example he had a Michael
Jordan's trainer Tim Grover on the
channel and he even had Mark Cuban on
the channel aside from this credibility
establishing videos Tai also posted a
bunch of videos that casually showed off
his lifestyle sometimes he was at
casinos sometimes he was in supercars
and other times he was just walking
around in his Mansion but regardless of
the background a few things were
constant which were the crappy
production quality and his apparent
indifference to the situation you would
usually never associate these attributes
with successful ad campaigns but this
was Thai secret formula these attributes
made it seem like Tai wasn't trying to
sell you anything and that he was
genuinely just sharing his thoughts and
wisdom all of this would build up to his
second most iconic video of all time
here in my backyard this video wasn't
all that different from any of his other
videos it pretty much followed the exact
same formula rather the reason this
video is so important is because people
with power would start questioning Ty's
credibility for the first time
foreign
the biggest channel that called out Thai
was h3h3 Productions he was able to find
Thai's house on Zillow now technically
the listing does say off-market but
Ethan from H3 would describe Zillow as a
short-term rental website and it
basically alleged that Tai was just
renting this house for his videos and
given that this video got over 6 million
views and it led to quite a bit of drama
more people would start looking at the
time and the more they looked the more
they realized that Tai basically had no
background or reputation other than the
one that he portrayed on his YouTube
channel for obvious reasons this made
people quite suspicious Tai would go on
to address this video head-on by
inviting Ethan to his quote-unquote
rented house Tai would give Ethan a tour
of the house and show him his supercars
and whatnot Tai was probably hoping that
this confrontation would give him more
credibility and it to his credit he did
explain himself pretty well he came
clean about how he didn't own many of
the things he showed off like his house
and cars and that he leased them instead
he also clarified that he leased these
items not because he couldn't afford
demo but because it made more financial
sense to lease and there is a truth to
this it makes no sense to sink a quarter
million into a Lamborghini or 15 million
into a mansion when you can invest this
money into things like Google Apple
Tesla the S P 500 or your own business
which would all likely generate far
higher returns so while Ty did have an
explanation as to why he released people
didn't exactly trust them and it wasn't
because his explanation was bad or that
people suspected that he wasn't actually
rich honestly his wealth never really
should have been the question from the
start to run the type of AD campaign
that Tyran you needed millions of
dollars so he either had this money
himself or he had access to investors
who had this money both of these
scenarios point to Thai being somewhat
Rich himself so that was never really
the question the real question was
whether this guy could be trusted and
this confrontation made it clear that
the answer to this question was a hard
no throughout the house tour we would
see a dozen or so attorneys bodyguards
investors or whoever they were monitor
each and every interaction and this just
raised a bunch of red flags pretty
quickly Tai went from being rich and
genuine to Rich and shady and that more
people started to see taizans for what
they really were not authentic life
advice but brilliantly designed ads and
a given that Ty's entire brand image was
built around his apparent authenticity
as this disappeared from the equation so
did test prominence and viewership this
isn't to say that Tai was doing bad
financially though Tai had already
convinced a large portion of his viewers
that he was some sort of a genius mentor
and these guys would continue buying
Ty's new courses making him even richer
so what Thai's internet popularity was
falling off a cliff the same could not
be said about his net worth
foreign
all of this brings us to where we are
today for the past few years Thai has
primarily been marketing to people who
have already bought into the Thai Lopez
brand but he has struggled to bring in
new people until recently and that
that's all thanks to YouTube shorts Thai
is by no means a new player when it
comes to short form content usually he
is very quick when it comes to Jumping
onto new trends of whether it be
Snapchat Instagram Tick Tock or YouTube
shorts but Thai wasn't gaining much
traction with this regular just trust me
bro advice so he started experimenting
with some other formats which led him to
a gold mine feel good shorts usually
this consists of soldiers returning home
acts of kindness and anything is
possible type motivation and let's just
say these shorts are exploding in
popularity Thai's most popular short has
a hundred million views and he has
dozens of shorts racking in millions if
not tens of millions of views each more
times than not I don't think the viewers
of these shorts even realize who's
posting them and even if they read the
name I don't think they actually know
who Tai Lopez even is this is extremely
powerful because it basically gives Taya
a brand new slate to work with these
people don't know anything about his
background and they just know that he
posts feel good videos if they start
following Kim because of these shorts
they'll eventually be served shorts
about his business advice leading to
more sales for his courses and the best
part about all of this for Thai is that
he doesn't even have to pay for this
exposure all of these views are
completely organic and that they're
getting more viewers than his paid ads
so far I haven't really seen anybody on
YouTube notice to his Resurgence but if
Tai keeps getting these number of views
it's just a matter of time until someone
starts exposing him all over again I'm
looking at Coffee Zilla here but in the
meantime Tai Lopez is very much back and
he's bigger than ever
foreign
and call him a scammer and yes the
bottom line is that he does sell
overpriced courses mainly consisting of
content that you can find for free on
the internet but this doesn't mean that
there's nothing to learn from him the
learning opportunity with Thai is not
his courses or whatever he's selling the
real learning opportunity with Thai is
this marketing his storytelling and his
persuasion now I'm not recommending that
you go sell online courses yourself but
maybe you could apply some of his
strategies into your own marketing
efforts if you're doing a job interview
how do you come off as authentic and
confident as opposed to rehearsed and
nervous if you own a business how do you
create a brand image that feels genuine
and resonates with your target market
Tai is clearly a master at this so as
Tai goes through the second wave of
popularity you shouldn't buy his courses
but you should pay close attention to
why Thai is winning but that's just what
I think the you think Tai Lopez is a
scammer a marketing genius or some
combination of both comment that down
below also drop a like if you hope
people see through Thai's pitch this
time around and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community to
suggest future video ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions are
also answered until then I'm Hari and
I'll see you guys on the next one